in the prize episodio è mica un ora in
this episode of zio ti ammazzo ti
ammazzo ti ammazzo te lo giuro
cos'era perdo di ragazzi venuti qui sono
video sono fa vigeo ci siamo trovati su
che mi hanno fatto benissimo
no non averti buran what the hell però
dovete stare calmi oggi la tv mi fate
capire un attimo cosa sta porca eva pc è
talmente andato forte che non si è
sentito neanche lo spiaccica mento
finale non ho capito il perché in realtà
non si è sentita anche il traguardo
vabbè non si è sentito un caffè hadopi
veloce del suono giant for and grill ma
sei serio perché c'è un ciak di
cavadonna
le iene che bello schiacciare i miei
simili a sé adatto come cazzo è
possibile ma non fatte a fare una roba
del genere scusate ci prova anche
incazzare una domanda porca eva e botta
cani caimi ragazzi calmi io sono il più
grosso nonno jacques grosso più grosso
il bebè a a van
i fiumi mai nonno e poi è morto se
potessi prenderli addirittura serve
ancora più figo prova beh mi accontento
anche così beh vabbè cos'è un atleta
benaglio un pollice in su per questa
croazia non metterei poi non solo ai
ragazzi che cazzo fai o è scemo è il
dono già pilota che abbia mai visto però
allo stesso tempo e più bello quindi
fighissimo non potranno fare tutti così
è un'imposta che da una vita che non
facevano in posti che non fa una piega
che cazzo c'era un motivo sono facevo
più impulsivo da una vita ragazzi dalla
porta ma perché
io quanto vi odio lo regalo ve lo regalo
come cazzo è poco flip challenge ragazzi
è inventato una nuova cosa da poco ficts
challenge non ha invitato ancora nessuno
fa più mistero ma cerco perché sono
curioso poco flip trip vediamo come
elisa secret
oddio non lo scopriremo mai quale questo
segreto tutto fu per serino vediamo
questo ma qualora lancia inventata cazzo
che sfiga dov'è finito lo perso la spesa
ce la posso fare
cazzo cero dai e bellissima sta roba
veri che non c'ha avuto idea porca vacca
quanto è difficile figlio di un'amica
non ci riuscirò mai a 38 alla porta è di
riuscire a farlo ruotare tipo barca e va
chi morisse il cugino da isicom sa
veramente come ho fatto dai magistrati
[ __ ] dai non avevano vale questo
non vale dai ragazzi ma minchia cosa
così mi chiama da non ci voglio credere
ragazzi serio allora [ __ ] a livello
subito idea stupida mia di provare a
fare poco philippe faure leggendari cosa
vuol dire a parlare già sono le leggende
possono fare questo livello quindi
grazie di avermi chiamato subito
rapporto files il writing e zio forza
perfetti
veri perfetto esiste per i perfect sono
veri perfect sbagliatissimo in inglese
non volevo dire molto perfetto cosa può
essere più perfetto del perfetto questo
limbo era molto perfetto ok
quanta carta quante cose hai messo visto
livello zero ok ma basta guardaroba i
che io li odio i jet era tuttora il culo
ragazzi ce l'ho fatta non so per quale
motivo ma va bene motor run o facevano
uno decente stavolta dal trattato
veramente in modo penoso davvero davvero
credo sia la prima volta nella mia vita
che faccio un bottone al primo tentativo
credo e ma sono quasi sicuro che sia
così spy phone 30 per cento impossible
come 30 verso il giro e non li non
riesco a fare neanche porca [ __ ] dei
fermi un attimo
stavolta ce l'ho fatta ho messo un po di
tempo ma sono bravo
cazzola e hai fatto talmente tanta
strada che si è tornato indietro hai
fatto il giro del mondo zio a dar piano
perfetto
questo è buono questo è molto buono
questo è buonissimo che poi 30 per cento
imposti con grassi questo era
impossibile super segue i surfer questo
centro seguì surf non si chiamava subway
surfer a ok sono bravo chi giovanni
mapooro giovanni questa faccia giovanni
ma non si chiama giovanni asteroide
e vabbè che grafiche ragazzi tropic
thunder morto
sono esplosi dei vulcani e poi dopo un
po si è sentito a caso spike ok questo
era molto molto più rapido pop
la caduta degli haters tortura
quindi come primo avevo provato il più
non senso di tutti perfetto il prossimo
99 per cento dai primo questo o questo
mi sembra
ma questo non è un poco jump gli enti si
mi sono pagato questo è un fuoco jump
comunque c'è in realtà non è un i
prossimo ma va bene e non ci passo mai
non sono andato di vitasnella sta
settimana
porca eva non si passò scarso ok no
perché non ci penso eva è scemo poteva
fare l'anguillara ormai c'è un futuro
radioso come anguilla perfetto come
cazzo ci passò di qui in poi ma non ci
passerò mai che cosa ho fatto ai mezzi
ai giovani 0 a 0 i mai così frate
perfetto mamma mia che orgoglio era fake
quel pezzo tanto prenderlo nel culo
sicuramente non ti fa male zio no quanto
è difficile sto livello cazzo dai dai
dai ragazzi strangio la zio ti ammazzo
ti ammazzo ti ammazzo te lo giuro
cos'era
[Musica]
devi saltare sopra sopra litio sopra si
no tutta la tua madre ce la puoi fare
frazioni tipici ok
o no ma allora [ __ ] ho mica un ora
e mezza
se non prendo la moneta se non prendo la
[Musica]
non me la fa prendere zio
io